a new big shake-up to the president's
cabinet today Rex Tillerson fired a
secretary of state
CIA director Mike Pompeo has been named
to replace him here's the President on
the stunning news earlier Rex and I have
been talking about this for a long time
we we got along actually quite well but
we disagreed on things when you look at
the Iran deal I think it's terrible I
guess he fit it was okay I wanted to
either break it or do something and he
felt a little bit differently so we were
not really thinking the same with Mike
Mike Pompeo we have a very similar
thought process I think it's going to go
very well Rex is a very good man
I like Rex a lot this afternoon to
listen also appeared before microphones
I want to give recognition to the State
Department and our partners for a few of
their accomplishments under this
administration all of us we know want to
leave this place as a better place for
the next generation I'll now return to
private life it's a private citizen
there's a proud American proud of the
opportunity I've had to serve my country
god bless all of you
god bless the American people god bless
america
all right so dinner what did you make of
that in terms he wanted to do the
statement it was good that he was
allowed to do that yes I think so and so
that the timeline it's always
interesting a story for Washington DC
we've got a call apparently while he's
overseas from General John Kelly from
the White House chief of staff saying
hey this is coming and then Tillerson
cut his trip to Africa short comes back
he landed at 4:00 a.m. he found out he
was fired for sure in a tweet at 9:00
a.m. speaks to the president at noon and
then when he comes to the podium it was
almost like he was reluctant he was
somebody who did not want to be in
Washington he took great pleasure in
reminding everybody he was not from
Washington he didn't want to be a part
of it it wasn't didn't like the whole
aspect of it and then as he's speaking
you started to realize you know what
maybe he was really sort of starting to
really respect the work that with the
career foreign officials were doing he's
talked a lot about them but he had one
fatal flaw and that is that he had lost
the confidence of the
resident and around the country and the
world excuse me
once you see that there might be
daylight between a Secretary of State
and a president that's it you have to go
and so there will be a smooth transition
now as Mike Pompeo from the CIA comes
over to the State Department he and the
president will have to show and I think
they will a united front from the get-go
mm-hmm Jesse you know Pompeo had been
rumored to be up for the job and wanted
the job way back back really so there
was some discussion about this it really
didn't come kind of as a surprise system
people had been following it and
insiders in terms of the choice the
president has always expressed a
confidence and as you know very similar
viewpoints as Pompeo was somebody that
he felt that he could relate to very
well and trusted yeah they've always
gelled during these briefings that they
have on intelligence matters the
Democrats should be very happy he's
extremely hawkish about Russia much more
so than Rex Tillerson and the agree with
Dana there was just more than a little
daylight there was a lot of daylight
between Tillerson and President Trump
when it came to the Paris climate deal
the Iran sanctions moving the embassy to
Jerusalem and Israel and they undercut
each other publicly with the
Charlottesville situation and again on
the North Korean negotiations we all
remember the [ __ ] comment which was a
two to three-day story which was hard to
get over but I mean he's a great patriot
and a great man and a great businessman
and a great leader but they're gonna
have great leadership at state and I
love this woman believe her name is
jeanna Haspel who's gonna now gonna lead
the CIA and you know people are saying
that she was in charge of these black
sites where there was torture that was
happening she was just following orders
she didn't design the interrogation
program she was doing what she was told
to do and she's going to be terrific and
it's it's a real historic moment for a
woman to lead the agency okay I don't I
think she should be proud of what she
did she has to make decisions that a lot
of her critics don't have to make she
answered the call and that call forces
you to make decisions that could put you
in jail so the thing is if you are faced
with a potential terror attack that
could kill thousands and they say but if
you do this
you go to jail if you if you follow that
order you're wrong if you follow the
order that puts you in jail that makes
you a hero and they save lives and they
save lives so I think that she's a hero
and if she was a TV character she would
be hero a woman running a black site
that's that's it that's it that's a
great character but in real life I'm
sure the left will paint her as a killer
and a heinous person as for Tillerson do
not go on Celebrity Big Brother hold out
hold out for Dancing with the Stars
update your LinkedIn profile picture I
do I have to say this when he was hired
we loved Rex Tillerson he was like an
adult he was the the businessman who's
gonna come in and play it straight so I
think that I guess for me I'm a little
bit sad the way it's handled and I know
that it's not true that he was fired on
Twitter we know that that's not true he
was like but I still think that you know
I don't know he could have I mean we
know if you were hired by Trump don't
bring a lot of knickknacks and photos
and frame diplomas into your office
because you're not gonna be there very
long but for some reason I do feel that
Rex Tillerson should have been handled
better because he's obviously a very
good man I supported him as well what I
thought senator menendez got this right
today when he said this is more evidence
of commander chaos speaking of President
Trump so I'm watching they are Tillerson
and I'm waiting for Tillerson to say
something wonderful about having served
with honor president he never mentions
Trump not once he says we're all honored
to be people who are here have taken an
oath to serve the Constitution not a
word about Trump not a word about his
experience with Trump yeah fire hey what
is it I think it's worse than fired the
way he was fired just so disrespectful
again evidence of captain caste how many
people have left this administration
within the last few days I mean it's
hard to remember the Gary Cohen was just
last week and then you have a situation
where you know you look at what's going
on at state the morale terrible he was
breaking down the morale at state not
filling positions out of touch with the
White House I think he'll go down as one
of the worst secretary of states if not
the worst in American history
that seems worse than Hillary wins even
close